[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and uh
it's 2019 and obviously everything leaks
so of course it's never too early for a
little bit of pixel hype and boy is
today a good day for some of that so if
you've been following pixel 3 for the
past couple months you know comparing it
to other phones we've been asking google
for so long now to step up their
hardware game to match their incredible
software that's always been like a
slightly weaker point with the pixels
and it looks like they've finally done
it for 2019. so this is your exclusive
first look at the google pixel 4 for
2019. there it is
that's the phone okay so there's a lot
to take in here of course things like
why does it look so different why does
it have that wedge looking thing why
does it look like it's in a case but
luckily not only do i have this leak but
i also have a bunch of information i
have some sources some exclusives so i
can explain it all so my sources are
close to the situation but they wish to
remain anonymous but i trust them with
my life there a hundred percent on this
kind of stuff uh and they have the
answers first of all these leaked images
come as a picture of the phone with a
clear case on it so that's why it might
look kind of weird with that sort of an
outline but that's what's happening you
can clearly see the outline of a clear
case around the pixel 4. and they're
really going bezel-less like the rest of
the competition the chin is of course
tiny the side bezel's minimal and
there's a fingerprint reader now
underneath the display glass on the
front and as you can see the screen goes
right all the way up to the top and then
there's a motorized selfie camera shelf
that looks like a shark fin and as a
matter of fact that is the device's
internal code name so it's pretty common
before a phone comes out for it to have
an internal name that everyone the
employees refer to it as an internal
code name and google's for the past
couple years with pixels and nexus
devices have notoriously been fish
related so the nexus 7 tablet before it
came out was internally referred to as
grouper and then the nexus 10 the bigger
tablet before that came out that was
called manta like a manta ray the nexus
4 was called mako as in mako shark nexus
5 was hammerhead and then nexus 6 was
infamously uh shamu so the whale and
then the first pixel was called sailfish
so google is clearly sticking to those
roots with pixel 4 internal code name
shark fin because of the shark fin
selfie camera obviously it also looks
like google's doing a dual camera on the
back which is nice i'm thinking that's
an ultra wide camera because you can't
really fake ultrawide with software like
google's done a whole bunch of great
stuff with one camera in the past but
you can't do ultra wide if you don't
have an ultrawide lens so a second
camera super ultra wide lens that's
great and then my source says it should
have the latest specs snapdragon 855
eight gigs of ram great and then the
power button and volume rocker are in
the same traditional place the squeeze
functionality is also still intact so
why was google able to suddenly step up
their hardware game
so fast for this pixel 4. and why does
this remind me of that leak i just saw
last week of that oppo reno phone well
my source says google recently completed
a silent acquisition of the mobile
hardware team at oppo this is totally
exclusive never before seen information
so that's why the pixel 4 looks exactly
like that oppo reno leak that we saw
last week and i actually believe this is
an intentional leak take another closer
look at this apple image
[Music]
so at first it looks like a random
collection of colorful artsy images
nothing to see here but
why else would they have a magnifying
glass
and a microscope clearly they want us to
look closer here so if you look even
closer so there's a whale over there and
that's an obvious hint at the sea life
in all their previous code names and
there's a camera over there all the way
over to the side that's clearly a signal
at how proud google is of their cameras
and it's a dslr with a wide-angle lens
on it meaning it'll have the ultra wide
camera as that second lens confirmed and
then what is this like around the plane
it's like some sort of plant
like a like a beanstalk
like jack in the beanstalk okay
okay so that's how okay that's how you
tell us we're getting a pixel 4 with a
jack a headphone jack well played google
well played and then there's some sort
of monkey or lemur which i wasn't sure
what species it was supposed to be until
i saw the elephant which is clearly an
african elephant which if it wasn't
obvious by the globe hanging down that
shows africa i mean come on guys so of
course i looked up species of lemurs
that are native to africa turns out this
one most closely resembles a red-tailed
sport of lemur native to madagascar fun
fact and red tailed clearly means that
they want the letter under the tail to
be red so we can turn that e
red and then above the letter n is
clearly a magnifying glass on the color
yellow so they want the letter under
that magnifying glass to be yellow duh
so you turn that yellow which gives you
the four colors of the letters now blue
red
yellow
blue
are you getting it it reminds you of
anything
blue
red
yellow
blue okay so last bit i think they just
threw this in for fun for the people who
didn't get all that uh they just called
it the oppo reno pretty obvious reno
backwards is owner
as in owner
as in first project under a new owner
google so easy so clearly this is the
pixel 4 confirmed in every which way
but
that's not all we've also been waiting
for well over a year
for an additional device and we're
finally getting it there is also a pixel
4
ultra so this is a clip of the pixel 4
ultra launching alongside this phone
courtesy of our guy dave 2d
[Music]
it's just beautiful it's so beautiful
so yeah clearly leaks are getting pretty
serious in the tech world and you got to
look you got to look a little deeper
than just the surface level when you see
a leak this is how you get to the next
level i even tossed it in an ocr program
and i saw those characters in between
oppo and reno and of course we know oppo
is or was a chinese company so i
translated the ocr image into characters
in english
and i got uh
april fool
nice
so this is your annual reminder uh not
to take any announcements or any new
products too seriously for the next 24
hours but i hope you enjoyed this one
anyway um but what isn't a joke is the
new drop in the mkbhd merch store
including this and a bunch of all
favorites are coming back including this
new thing
uh a matte black microfiber i was kind
of getting tired of those like thin ones
they just kind of toss in everything the
microfibers you see everywhere so this
is a high quality one you can actually
use on everything laptop phone tablet
just want to kill them all thanks bixby
so i'll link to everything below also
shout out to dave2d for helping out with
this video and his glorious beautiful
pixel 3 or pixel 4 mock-up appreciate
that dave anyway until the next one
happy april fool's day thanks for
watching
catch you guys next one
peace